hey everyone welcome back to new
rockstars news it's a big week in the
news of Game of Thrones we got a big
update courtesy of Entertainment Weekly
who did a whole write-up on the show's
final season and it's got some like
surprising level of detail in terms of
these shows the final season's first
episode there's six episodes in the
final season they're all like movies and
what the final episode might look like
the cast reactions and they gave us some
big clues it's super cool probably the
biggest week in Game of Thrones news
since season 7 so we're gonna go all
into it but we also got some more
details on the Disney streaming service
in a new show that's coming out there an
update on the movie birds of prey and
Aquaman and if you stick around to the
end I'll tell you a bit about Henry
Cavill sweet new hairdo it sure is it's
due it's a do not a dolt
well welcome again to new rockstars news
salmon mod Sam is here mod is not
Phillip in mod are not able to join us
this week but I'm Erik Bosse Sam
bachelor we're gonna give you all the
details that dynamic fun yeah you guys
been begging for a you've been shipping
hard clone at our door right yeah well
we were bringing it but let's get
started with our top story
Game of Thrones and there's so much here
boy oh boy oh boy I highly recommend you
check out this Entertainment Weekly
write-up because you just got to read
the whole thing I almost miss until you
guys brought it up and I sat down I just
read through it really quick it's a it's
a good so we got you covered
yeah but let's run through all the big
details all the highlights first off the
season will open oh and I should say
spoiler warning in case you don't want
to know you gotta insert that obligatory
spoiler warning or they'll call you on
it
no get ya watchdogs are everywhere okay
so the season will open at Winterfell
with the arrival of Daenerys in her army
and no big surprise there we knew that's
where they were headed back after
leaving the conference with Cersei at
the end of season seven and this is the
quote from the writer of this what
follows is a thrilling intense
intermingling of the characters I'm
imagining he's like a British elevator
lift in Cryptkeeper
yeah yeah all elevators don't work in
England so there they end up being Crips
I've just made that up
I hear the UK watchdogs come in my way
now okay so an intensive intermingling
of characters some of whom have never
previously met many who have messy
histories in quote now there's a lot of
different couples who that could be
referring to those people pretty much
all a lot of them haven't met Ari it
hasn't met him anyone for the show so
imagine how Arya would feel meeting
well she's met tyrion lanister seasons
yeah they didn't really talk a whole lot
but Arya certainly not met anyone in
Daenerys his group at all I'm sure she
has some opinions about that but also
let's not forget like people who would
be allies just buy some of Daenerys his
decisions last season after the Battle
of the what's the loot train battle
where she torched all of the the
Lannister army she executed Sam's father
and his brother now he hated his father
yeah he hated mr. Tarly I think he
didn't like his family in general but
his brother was always fairly nice too
yeah maybe I don't know it was intense
it was a little extreme yeah
also it was one of the coolest shots the
entire it was you see them turn to ash
immediately so I don't know we'll see if
Sam holds a grudge there I'm sure he's
gonna say something about it but the
article specifically mentions that Sansa
is not thrilled about Jon's knee bending
that's really interesting because it's
like well yeah they they have not been
interacting I mean that you did get some
interaction since like season 1 and 2
but it's like I don't know why Sansa
would be specifically upset about this
that's why I'm really excited to see
what they do I mean there's not that
many Starks left so I get why she's a
little rusty about new people coming in
well she didn't want him to go meet with
Daenerys at Dragonstone because she felt
that the last time a stark tried to bend
the knee to a Targaryen
he ended up sending us on a path of
destruction like their grandfather was
murdered by her grandfather okay yeah by
the Mad King they went down to King's
Landing and he got
to life because like I was crazy now
Daenerys isn't as mad but she has made
some brash decisions right yeah
obviously Daenerys and John's
relationship is much there's different
kinds of heat there incestual heat so
it's not that uh we don't to worry about
that necessarily but in terms of like
loyalty and tribalism and team colors
right you could imagine Sansa Stark
being like look we all sacrifice so much
to make you King in the north and to
rally support we we criss-crossed around
the northern countryside Oh in the blink
of an eye I'm bending that they do on
the show but we sacrificed a lot to make
you King and now you're bending the knee
to another monarch that's kind of crappy
why would you do that but I think I feel
like she could get on board pretty quick
when they're like but yes sir she's not
for us it's like oh if we're all against
her then maybe this we actually might
have a chance of taking out the
Lannisters once and for all yes she's
Aryan yeah - Tyrion and you know they
kind of made this alliance with Cersei
at the end of season seven we found out
Cersei was like hey after they left so I
could imagine Sansa maybe spreading some
doubt like listen whatever assurances
you got from that Lannister down south
don't listen to her and there wasn't one
brief shot that we got in the HBO promo
right a couple months ago of like all of
our new shows and there was one shot
from Game of Thrones that's like Sansa
hugging Jon and giving that cold icy
stares like that's probably gonna be
dinner I'm excited to see where Jamie's
at with all this and I wouldn't bring
him up but it's that since him leaving
and him finally making that decision
it's just like this show did so much
work to make him a good guy I'm like I'm
wondering where he's gonna end up
especially when he runs in the Aria
right if eclis I'm like this is gonna be
that scene specifically I think that's
gonna it's gonna hurt it's gonna hurt
those two characters arguably have
changed the most out of everyone yeah
like Jon and Daenerys have certainly
gone on their hero's journey but in
terms of their values I would say
they're roughly you know where they were
from season two on they kind of became
bad assets by the end of season one and
they've they've kind of just gone
further and further on trajectory and
physically have changed in terms of
status and power of change in terms of
like their values like I would say Jamie
and Arya have it several different
points reach several different areas on
their arcs you know like Aria went from
wanting to join the faceless men to be
trained then
to kind of be in a rogue assassin who's
kind of mad at her sister - coming to
terms with her sister when she arrived
back at Winterfell and then Jamie has
gotten different points - having this
connection this platonic connection with
Brienne maybe more maybe maybe more
which would make me happy but I'm never
allowed to be happy with I mean most
laurel out to be happy on the show
anyway so yeah everyone is on constant
verge of heartbreak thanks to Georgia or
Martin but that's why we love the show
but let's we got some more details from
this story the article also mentions an
episode directed by Miguel Capote Nick
and this is a guy who did battle the
Basterds he's one of the best most
talented directors on that they have in
their lineup and according to this
article it's gonna be a huge battle
between the living and the dead and
according the article this has been
something that they've been dreaming
them since the very first episode and
they knew that from george RR martin
this is kind of where the show is going
great shot by the way that's immediately
what popped in my brain I'm like I can't
I can't wait I can't wait for Dragon vs.
dragons dragon vs. fire dragon yet and
the article seems to suggest it's gonna
take place at Winterfell they've
expanded the Winterfell set so that
actually it's like the real size of a
city rather than just like a courtyard
in the White Walkers of course coming
from the north it's probably gonna be
with their first step after breaching
the wall oh yeah it's I mean there's
other big cities there's well there's
Castle black further down the wall but
there's there's a other where the
Karstarks lived there's part hold
there's other stuff so they can get you
before but really if you're gonna build
one set and have a huge battle there why
not make one we care about his
Winterfell if you want to stretch it out
a little bit but it's the last season
please don't stretch anything out just
go straight to the right meat of the
story and yeah there's a lot of payoff
that we're kind of hoping for but what I
like about this because I was I heard a
lot of things about others gonna be a
big battle and you know as much as I
love battle the bastards and like the
battle at Blackwater I think people
think like big battle they think like
Lord of the Rings big like Prairie that
everyone's just huge waves of soldiers
yeah to me sometimes I check out and I
was glad to read that the showrunners
felt the same way they're like if you
just pitch massive battle just like
walls of people slamming against each
other sometimes I can feel boring and
what they've done really well in battle
the bastards in the Blackwater Bay
battle they specifically show threads
within it of you see it from specific
points of view so it feels like there's
different intercutting things that you
can check in with
this character and there's on this
ground level versus an aerial level you
know windage on different angles when
John's getting trampled in the mud
I was trampled one time when I was a kid
because we were scared at a after-school
program and kids like ran over me
so that I have like it's like a
recurring nightmare about that school it
was a Christian school so they saw one
scary thing like the ax man and they ran
so they ran all over me but um no I
would that specific feeling I was like I
kind of need to pause this scene for
just a second but no that's a really
good point it's just it's very specific
you're seeing how these like pick five
characters these are how they this is
how they're affected and you get a few
aerial shots every once in a while to
give you a like a picture of the scale
it's awesome yeah yeah and it sounds
like these point of view are gonna be so
well defined with each of the characters
so they cut to that's gonna feel like
its own genre which is an interesting
way to describe it in this article like
it's gonna feel like a horror film
if you cut to one character who's like
in the darkness because it sounds like
they shot a lot of this at nighttime
there's a headline that we saw that like
455 nights they shot outdoor shots for
some battle I don't know if it's this
battle but just imagine like White
Walkers in the darkness just like
bursting out at you and taking you and
so you disappear in the darkness whereas
another person it kind of ends up being
like a straight a medieval battle so I
mean evil battle you get your action you
get your like superhero type like hero
going through you get your slapstick
comedy yeah or your notebook romance
yeah yeah you gotta have one animated
segment just one I love this it's like
it becomes like pop and cartoons
yeah well last detail that we want to
talk about is the article offered up a
couple teases of the series finale and
it will include according to the writer
a set that we have never seen before
characters that the writer did not
expect to see and the writer said that
while looking around he was able to
gradually begin to piece together what
had transpired in Westeros over the
previous five episodes of that season to
figure out like how the puzzle pieces
could have come together for this finale
and they started to freak out cool Italy
kind of retro actively doing the math on
it nice so I don't know on what's your
general expect well yeah I got a
question for you alright on a scale of 1
to Clegane Bo how excited are you for
Game of Thrones Season eight ya
cleganebowl ^ cleganebowl interesting
yeah well I mean Kalitta yeah don't want
to see clicking bulow because like in
the reddit comments we were like oh
we're gonna see Clegane ball it's like
what you're describing to me now sounds
way more exciting that just seen that
these two brothers who hate each other
end up having a fight I do kind of want
to see them fight side by side
disappointed OH side by side sucky
have they locked their battle axes and
then they turn back to back and start
Rae and be Halloween be so weird because
that's just like meat running around at
this point for the mount it's not like a
person anymore it doesn't count
yeah but I mean I'd be I mean at least
turn on its head this show does a good
job with that I do want to see it but I
want to all characters just meet in
George RR Martin's eyes ready to be
slaughtered yes the core seems illusions
there you go those are important but no
I'm I'm so I hopped into this show last
year because I was one of those kooky
bores like Game of Thrones and then I
watched it all I was like all right I
was annoying before I get it all right I
understand and so it was it's I don't
even I don't even know how to even build
my expectations so I'm just not going to
I'm not gonna because I'm just gonna go
into this and allow these storytellers
to tell me something that's fully
original to them it's it's on it honors
what George RR s started and I hope our
characters are at least end up 50% happy
yeah
that's all I want really and we want a
bittersweet ending you know we we don't
want something that's just it gives us
everything we want
you know Game of Thrones has never been
something that's truly just about
fanservice and I think when people have
been less excited about certain moments
on the show certain episodes that's when
they have tried to be too like we're
gonna give you everything you want with
this moment right now it's it's usually
better when we walk away a little
disappointed or a little stung we feel
we have to limp out of an episode that
relationship I know everyone likes Ally
with Daenerys and John I'm their aunt
and yeah they really should not live
happily ever know that would be
contradictory data shows keep Khan
central core messages I go on a couple
shows and people are like no no like we
it's like different there and I'm like
please stop saying that like that saying
it's not the same we can't keep saying
that that's gross we said that
me and Circe you're gross so that's
gross - that's hey no I'm don't want to
be too gross so I'm gonna say this
happened anecdotally from someone who
told me a friend of mine said that he
has noticed recently while going on a
pornographic website said a lot of the
related recommended videos have been
incest themed there so and and I have
seen because every year pornhub posts
it's like number one top genres has
spiked in recent years in terms of like
the genre porn I think Game of Thrones
is normalizing incest in a weird way and
it's not like look you're into what
you're into I don't want to kink shame
anyone but like it's not good for your
child it's it's there's a lot of genetic
problems when you start mixing the gene
pools like that so you know we saw what
happened with the Mad King right it is a
product of incest it we saw what
happened with Joffrey a product of
incest on the show so let's not look at
it as positing let's all try to have
Tyrians reaction on the boat - the boat
sex he did not look happy about that a
surrogate proxy for us we should feel
ups Aryan feels about that pairing
we should not ship them but actually
let's move on to a more Game of Thrones
news because it wasn't just for the
show's final season as sad as we may be
that the show's ending the prequel
series is coming out at least one of
them the show tentatively titled the
long night so this is a show that sounds
like it's taking place in the Age of
Heroes right and they announced casting
for two of its leads
Naomi Watts plain quote a charismatic
socialite hiding a dark secret everyone
right now what is a socially it sounds
like such a 1920s gatsby done secretive
socialite charismatic kind the dark
secret decided to pull up my bloomers
this season lady Grantham who is a
social degree voiced by the way the idea
of a socialite if you look at the Age of
Heroes I don't know if this gonna take
place specifically up north on the land
of Westeros or something around the doom
of Valyria I know there's another
prequel series in the work I don't that
could be talking about that but you
back when we talk about the Valyrian
culture that's like Rome that's like
ancient Rome and there were social
classes that's worth the targaryen x'
originated from Valyria from the doom of
Valyria and that's that's very
interesting to see like the class
structure of that before the world comes
to an end so we'll see if that's what
the social light referred to there well
he always wants some political dramas I
said being thrown I'm a big fan Naomi
I'm excited to see what they do in
character yeah she's awesome they've
also announced Josh White House a
British actor he's gonna be playing a
lead role all the details of the
character are still being kept under
wraps he sure looks like a stand-in for
Jamie though so maybe that means
something
yeah Naomi wants blonde hair my first
go-to thing is that she's playing some
kind of remember the Targaryen family
just some thoughts that we might be
seeing some roots of the lannister
family with me and the clever I thought
that when I first like my first looked
at her I was like I can see that a
little bit but also blue eyes so maybe
like Targaryen as well like you can see
that as well but with our boy over here
honestly that could be just about
anybody that that not a new character a
new character but I am interested to see
I mean I wish they just give us just a
little bit more detail about this I
would expect probably like a teaser or
trailer in the finale of the of this
season like something like right but
stay after the credits for Baba yeah
that'd be great
my guess is that they're gonna use the
ratings blockbuster time that they're
gonna have with this summer for Game of
Thrones to spin-off two Watchmen cuz
watchman's gonna be their new show
yeah next fall and I think that's what
they're gonna try to get us excited
about but yeah I'd be what I hope
because it's rare that spin-offs work I
think you know it's hard for TV to do a
prequel series in a way to feel
satisfying I think better call Saul has
been like an example of one that has
worked the best example it has not
reached the heights that Breaking Bad
has I prefer popularity like I am you
hear people talk about it and they're
the diehard fans but ya know like 100
percent it's I don't know how they
they're able to keep people on
for this long but it's definitely a
example of something that works you know
I also kind of want this show before I
want watchman but that's just a
different opinion I think well I just I
know that I like the the property of
Game of Thrones I want to see more
stories in Westeros I've been wanting to
see more stories in Westeros and the
duncan egg stories from George or Martin
are fascinating so I think if and he is
executive producing this new and so his
voice is still gonna be attached to it
I'd rather have him finished book six in
book seven but you know if we're gonna
get more Game of Thrones TV I'd rather
have him be attached to it and attached
to it than not but yeah I think this
could really work and I of the two ideas
of the Age of Heroes versus like
something taking place in old Valyria I
think I've always been interested in the
doom of Valyria yes I always want to see
the dramatize for me for not like doing
because you did the breakdowns and
whatnot any like research I've ever done
for this is very it's very shallow it's
I've never really liked taking a dive
into it and also feel like there isn't
too much information about it so you
could there's a lot of room for the
writers to really open it up and create
a new world a world that's supposed to
be the it Valerius sounds like it's
magical basically it's it is bright like
for the most part like it sounds like a
place that we actually would want to
visit more than I don't want to go back
to Braavos please somebody go back there
how long and other banks there and
what's my stakes banking drama with the
cdc's and loans guys this is this is why
our lives are screwed it's because
banking is boring there you go we got to
figure out how to make it more
interesting no Duma velarium please
thanks no yeah I I think what what is
exciting about Valyria is like it's that
whole idea of an entire civilization
existing before a natural calamity and
you know there there's been stories
about like did aliens helped the
Egyptians build the pyramids this whole
idea of well the parents were built
after the Ice Ages but the Ice Age is
wiped out whatever was there before the
dinosaurs I want to see the The Land
Before Time but there's a lot more
coming from the worlds of Game of
Thrones so along with a final climactic
season we're gonna be getting a whole
new
world beginning but let's move on to a
trivia question guys and as always the
stakes of this gif of Shane losers got
to turn into an animated gif and look
like a big old dumb dumb but here's a
question in this week's Sam are you
ready you better never been more ready
in Game of Thrones lore the Age of
Heroes is when many of our favorite
houses were founded for example House
Stark was founded by bran the Builder
who founded House Lannister okay all of
our answers are here in the buckets of
where we are litter bug it or bucket
bucket so all our answers there at the
end of the episode we're be able to
answer the trivia question or winner
we'll do our goodbyes our loser will
join the gift of shame and Sam you've
been a regular frequent oh yes I'm a
regular member just me yeah and
membership of thank you it's not happen
this week it's been a big week of news
oh it has been buckle up kids huh cuz
we've got an artbook coming is cooler
than you think next week Tuesday
November 6 Marvel's Avengers infinity
war the art of the movie will be
released it's awesome it's the whole
book of concept art you got character
art production photos really cool stuff
I have about like four of these at home
and I've definitely shared saved space
for this one I'm very excited black
panther as well it's a good one a lot of
Pixar ones big fan of but I'm excited to
check this out and see all the stuff
that they were maybe going to put do
differently in the movie like you can
see here you got cap with slightly
shorter hair I also got like a hip scarf
oh boy you know what it's a little nippy
outside so fall weather it's a balmy 60
degrees he's feeling an espresso eat
your Bracken spice cap there that's how
I prefer my cap he's got a heck of a
beard yeah this is great
no I was being careful but Eric sorry I
was distracted by the pumpkin spice what
did you I what are you most excited
about when it comes to this book because
we're gonna be getting a lot more
details I'm excited to see alternate
costumes I always love the guardians
books in particular because I like the
way the James can the arc team would try
to realize these cosmic characters in
different ways like rocket I always had
cool designs Gamora was the one that was
always like what are you gonna actually
do with him and Drax cuz Drax is so
simplistic and
it's just ice and he's green and now
they really brought him to life and made
him very unique when it comes to
Gomorrah if they added cybernetic
enhancements and then you can actually
see them but I'm actually really excited
to see what the other ways they thought
of bringing like the Infinity Gauntlet
to life like what elder does not because
it has like scarabs oh yeah there's all
kinds of ancient runes on it you know
it's fascinating because when you watch
infinity war one of things I loved about
it is the production design like they
come actually came with some very clever
ways to depict the action which you
don't always see these big climactic
battles we've seen movies where they
don't do well infinity war really did
pull it off and these battles they have
like this epic scale to them that feels
unique to the characters like that
one-on-one duel between Doctor Strange
and Thanos they're just firing spells at
each other oh it feels like honestly an
even better version of the Dumbledore
Voldemort fight in order the Phoenix
where they had the elements they had the
earth wind water fire here they were
kind of doing that he was firing like a
mirror dimension that turned into a
black hole it honestly felt like Marvel
said to them the sky's the limit
when it comes to our visual effects
budget whatever crazy crap you want
these characters to do we can pull it
off and they did like we got iron spider
in this concept art you can see Iron Man
has this like lobster claw grip maybe to
wrap around the Infinity Gauntlet and
yank it off and you got nebula there you
got mantis as well like there's a lot of
cool things and you get you get to see
right off the bat you see star-lord
jumping on the little there's a couple
different names from there cuz appease
the frisbees the magic frisbee is the
technical term yeah and the other ways
they want to interpret the characters
like I remember in one of the pitches
the Russos were like oh we didn't want
captive show up until the last second of
this movie where I was like and that
would have been awesome what do you how
did you picture that happening and I
hope that's in the book as well yeah I
think there were fit I think the idea
was they wanted him his entrance to be
like Thor's entrance how that was big
like applause momen infinity wars for
screening cap and I think a lot of test
audiences like we wanted more cap in
this movie so they're like alright well
we'll put him in the first part of the
movie as he still gets a pretty cool
entrance he gets very okay ominous music
there was another image from the concept
art that I saw that had like Doctor
Strange putting like his
on danos like right and like his third
eye area and putting Danis are in a
trance and I don't know if that that
they're gonna talk to stranger that
instead of mantis and that's how he's
gonna be put in that kind of state of
paralysis the hypnotism but it also made
me think like Oh was part of dr.
Strange's plan at some point to like
read Thanos his thoughts and maybe
that's how they were gonna discover what
he did to Gamora there's just a lot of
because it reminded me a lot of when the
ancient one does that too strange was
like open your eye and in doctor
training zips through the magical
mystery tour of the different realities
maybe the plan was to do that with
Thanos just to melt his brain yeah we
think a psychedelic trip I think I think
they knows won't be able to control that
I don't think he would yeah yeah but
we've been struggle right he just got
the reality stone maybe that's how he
would have to like use that to like grab
on at the edge of a reality and like fly
back in because there was also concept
art of like Stannis having to fight in
some like wormhole portal looking thing
like it's real trippy stuff and I didn't
know if that was just part of like wind
dr. strange through the mirror dimension
at him and then he turned into a black
hole and fired it back at him we're
gonna see some version of that and
that's what that art was depicting as
opposed to them fighting through
different Rick and Morty style dimension
there yeah which way I would have been
fine but I would have that's what I
wanted the whole movie but no I think
most of all I'm excited to see we didn't
know that you bring it up the Doctor
Strange magic I want to see how they
interpret that I want to see what the
Russos do with that because or what they
wanted to do with that because they're
they just have such a good knack at
nailing these characters I'm like well
how else did you see this character
coming to life in your movie he was
crazy as like dr. strange has been the
most like beneficial gift giver in terms
of like different theories the most
unopened book I would say like the movie
came not everyone was that I like the
movie but not everyone holds Doctor
Strange like their Marvel top 5 I would
say yeah it's like oh he's here he
introduced the time stone were good but
like dr. Strange's abilities are so
fascinating and the way he looks at the
universe and the cosmos is unlike any
other character so this whole idea of
like dr. Strange's plan has given us
like endless things to talk about on
this channel thank you yeah thanks dr.
strange so he's the character I want to
explore the most or at least you know
the whole idea of the mystic arts and
injuries for I think there's a lot of
untapped potential oh yeah also
alternate looks for Bucky's arm would be
really down to see what he got the new
firm yeah we got the blue and the gold
not bad not bad but I would like to see
some alternatives also when we get into
that solo serious all right seeing if
like what if he's got interchangeable
arms why not well let us know what you
think about this art book or what other
details did you spot in the comments
below
yeah there's we got some time before we
will get an Avengers 4 trailer by the
end of this year but we got some reading
to do before that happens it sounds like
but you mentioned the Disney streaming
show news that we got this week this
Disney streaming service it's gonna be
an coming out sometime in 2019 last week
we learned that there is a bigger and
better series in that rumored Nick Fury
show but this week we found out we think
what it is or one of them may be
apparently a falcon Winter Soldier
limited series is in the works
Malcolm Spellman is gonna be running the
show he's an empire writer he's written
a bunch of other stuff very very
talented guy now
this Falcon Winter Soldier limited
series and the Loki Scarlet Witch
limited series would both be produced by
Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios and have
sizable budgets great news oh that makes
me feel good oh yeah so what do you
think this show would focus on like what
specifically about Falcon and Bucky
Barnes its characters like what do they
have in common other than you would say
being BFFs with Captain America by the
way I do we'll have a little tidbit I
learned this week about the Scarlet
Witch show but focusing on this question
when it comes to Falcon or Bucky Barnes
they're both characters that haven't
actually spent that much time together
yeah they even when they were on the run
Bucky was spending his time in Wakanda
recovering they only spent maybe like a
day two days in civil war they like were
on a road trip and then they tried to
fight spider-man together and that's
yeah that's it and but they had a really
great rapport immediately so when it
comes to this there's a recent retelling
or they are new installment in tales of
suspense which is a classic Marvel title
when it comes to spy stories and it was
a Hawkeye and the Winter Soldier teaming
up to find Black Widow because she was
on the run don't need to get the comic
reasons of what was happening but it was
interesting to see these two characters
going after a spy like a top models by
so I would like to see these two go into
like
espionage or something like that a good
spy story that would take place in like
pick a pick a random country or have it
take place over multiple countries like
having a be used to in like London
that'd be really cool that sounds like a
great idea because if you think these
two were introduced in Captain America
the Winter Soldier which was an
espionage film one of the best Marvel
movies and I think some limited series
that's in that tone of them like kind of
uncovering some other government secret
or some kind of cover-up or some old
like Soviet espionage espionage dealing
with Scarlett Johansson as a as Black
Widow would be fascinating I wouldn't
mind if they did they we I don't know
this character is pretty much dead but
Armand Zola that he was in sure when I
was downloading his brain he's in
computer form somewhere he was a virus
in the inside project if somebody hacked
into Bucky's arm I think that'd be
really getting like messages or
something yeah and they kind of helped
bring arm and Zola back that could be a
fun way of doing it rip like playing
with caps villains they can play with
basically anybody which is really cool
and since the MCU there's so many
smaller characters that they would never
need never have time to deal with him
but we were also talking before we were
recording but limited series great those
are great worries those are good
keywords I'm fine with them never doing
another 13 episode series of anything
unless they're like 20 minute episodes
then just make a movie you don't even
split them up like that but I was
talking with a friend and we threw out
the idea of doing it kind of like
Sherlock BBC where you get yeah three
two hour episodes so you getting three
movies and I'm like man that's actually
a really cool also war machine would be
another character that could be really
cool with this but no I would I would
like you going to going with spies and
also they both have military backgrounds
maybe it's a war story something like
that there's a lot of avenues you can go
and if they have the money to support it
get like a plus casting a villain get
some cameos the rest of it I think
what's really exciting about this series
if you compare it to the Scarlet Witch
Loki series it sounds like we have two
limited series one of which will deal
with characters with more like cosmic
mystic powers and two characters who are
both former soldiers in the world of
espionage yes of one series that's just
super grounded and focusing on that side
of the universe in another series that
focus on
character's going through like different
realms and dealing with the really
bizarre colorful characters like a fun
pairing I just thought about a big cat
in America villain that we could never
get I would say until now is MODOK and
if you've ever looked at him he's just a
head
giant about the size of a minivan flew
around the little arms there's a way to
adapt to DeMint not make him look
ridiculous but he is a very popular
Captain America villain that could be a
way if you give him the time took for
the audience to get to know them kind of
like how kingpin could get like he can
unfold that Kara can really dive into
like who he is like purple man as well
in the Netflix series you might have
enough time and enough room enough
budget to make that character work I
don't know if I want it but you could do
it he's a super he's unbelievably
intelligent and he's got the tech to go
up against these guys and it would be
interesting to see these guys have to
take them down or at some point I
wouldn't mind if one of them dressed up
as Captain America wouldn't be right one
of them gets to be called Captain
America or has somebody as a shield yeah
wouldn't wouldn't be mad about it also I
heard this week about it was a rumor
that came out that Scarlet Witch that
series is looking to have one of the
other main Marvel characters Avengers
being a co-star in that so everyone's
throwing out vision immediately they
like he's probably fine no doubt they'll
download him into an iPod or something
I'll be good yeah you'll be fine
I wouldn't mind that I would like to see
though that coupling or maybe you can
throw in like Doctor Strange
as like a mystic guide of teaching her
how to use your magic if they want to go
that direction Quicksilver maybe
bringing them back there's a lot of
avenues you can go with that as well
these shows have the potential to be
unbelievably amazing and I mean the
mandalorian looks amazing from John
Favreau
but this is the stuff that's this stuff
works I'm very excited to do Disney
streaming service seems to be really
doing it right like identifying what
properties are really gonna make people
want to pay whatever it is a month eight
twelve twenty dollars no no thirty money
just take it all take it all Disney
yeah but let us know what you're most
excited about with the series in the
comments below it looks like there's
some more news that came out if I may
this week it was announced that you and
McGregor we planned the villain black
mask in the upcoming birds-of-prey movie
so cool if you guys don't know here's
the synopsis for that film so buckle up
after splitting up with the Joker Harley
Quinn
and three other female superheroes Black
Canary Huntress and Renee Montoya come
together to save the life of a little
girl Cassandra Cain from an evil crime
lord now that crime lord of course is
being his black mask I think this is
actually genuinely good news he's a
great actor I've always been a big fan
yeah I know Moulin Rouge has problems I
do love him in it even though he's a
baby man and also he doesn't often play
a bad guy even though he did in Fargo
but Eric how excited are you do you
think this is a good choice I think it's
a great choice and like we're talking
like Fargo season 3 which it's an
excellent show if you're if you're
looking forward just like a really
well-constructed show know Holly's work
on that every season feels like a
different anthology it's fantastic
season 3 you and MacGregor plays
brothers he plays twin brothers he's
both characters and they're both evil
and dastardly in different ways and the
whole theme of that season is what makes
like someone a bad person because like
it starts with him playing like he has a
brother who's like really down on his
luck he's like a parole officer guy and
he's like kind of a bum he's overweight
he's rough but he kind of seems like a
scummy guy and his brother is a very
successful businessman but like
throughout the season you see a switch
in their morality and his brother become
the the rich successful brother is such
a rotten sold person so like you can see
and play two sides to split
personalities of like different takes on
what evil is and with the character of
black mask his whole thing is like
identity and in kind of a split
personality and in some versions of the
comics so think he really is a perfect
choice for this movie and like I'm
always down for you and get more work
this is interesting also this picture
that you guys pick because it's the one
where he had like a leather was it the
one from pulp fiction yeah
cuz usually it's like wow you guys can
correct because this is one of those
costume things that has changed just
depending on who's writing yes sometimes
it's like the wood from his father's
coffin ebony from yeah yeah I mean
sometimes it's like melted to his face
which makes 0 didn't get struck by
lightning at some point and it like
pardon oh yeah okay I'm not against but
yeah also a little fun fact casting
director of birds of prey I think it's
fair to speculate as a big fan of Fargo
like you mentioned because Mary
Elizabeth Winstead
playing Huntress is in this movie as
well so it's like hey you know Fargo
shocking FX usually is really good at
casting so maybe dip into that pool
they've got some good idea yeah also
Yuma great I just I like seeing more of
him I'm a big fan of him and I feel like
he kind of took a break for just a
little bit from acting I like him coming
back I like his resurgence so and also
just this movie is turning out to be
super compelling also Cassandra Cain
please shout out Cassandra Cain comments
cuz she's one of my favorite characters
she's so compelling she should be a
Robin in one of the movies and not don't
do the I know the boy Robins are fun and
you can have a lot of stories Cassandra
Cain though as Batgirl is so cool
anyways yeah it's definitely one of the
brighter spots on the DC movie lineup in
the future we keep hearing more and more
updates about this I'm excited about the
Joaquin Phoenix Joker movie he didn't
think I would be yeah but I the from
what I'm hearing about it which is way
too much for a movie that's still in
production between that in this
birds-of-prey movie I think it could be
definitely one of the brighter spots ins
now with James Gunn joining the team
with Suicide Squad to I don't know I
think the DC fans out there have had a
rough patch in terms of their favorite
properties not being that well adapted
but and those extras who got locked in
the subway instead peeing everywhere
great spots okay let's get to some other
just quick news updates for what else
happened this week so we got our first
look at mr. Henry Cavill in The Witcher
2 yeah a lot of people online like to
point out that he doesn't have a beard
like in the most recent game and then
other people like to point out that in
the books he doesn't have a beard so
there's an acknowledgement to that yep
there you go we also got an announcement
for it chapter 2 a release date of
September 6 2019 that's actually the
same weekend that the first it chapter
came out in 2017 that movie looks super
exciting from the casting we've had it's
it's um it sounds like they asked the
young actors from the first movie
what adult actors they want to have to
play the adult versions of themselves
and they kind of got a lot of them to do
it some good but you know haters playing
the fin wolfhard character growing up
and that was his dream pick for it
Ritchie James McAvoy and Bill Hader and
a scene together I just feel like that's
the case so interesting I'm so excited
for it yeah yeah we also learned that
Aquaman will include a lot of flashbacks
of the heroes past uh-huh it makes sense
yeah orjan sure yeah and a few updates
fun things we've covered previous
episodes actually James Gunn they're
announced he's also directing suicide
Suicide Squad - that makes surprise like
you're bringing a guy he's a talent
director and in addition to a talented
writer so if you're gonna bring him on
might as well get everything out of him
and according to Vincent D'Onofrio
kingpin was Fisk from daredevil he has
said that Netflix has no intention of
canceling daredevil I guess people are
worried with Iron Fist with Luke Cage
getting cancelled is daredevil next
chopping block there's a website out
there that the way that they somehow got
in numbers but they're not like official
Netflix numbers they're like Netflix
easin 3 has half the viewership of
season two and I'm like hmm well you
don't actually as far as I could tell
from the what I read it didn't seem like
the most concrete things yeah you can't
find their don't get too sad yeah they
don't release it there's super secretive
about what the ratings are because
they're like you know they're from tech
companies they're not like movie studios
who like to brag about what ratings do
things get they're like no we are nodes
we do not need to release how many
people are consuming our content and we
just have to go off of like google
search trends and and that kind of stuff
which yeah I mean maybe people s fewer
people are searching for it on Google
but that doesn't necessarily tell you
how many people on Netflix are watching
something true yeah so don't trust the
numbers out there but yeah I also
wouldn't trust actors being asked
whether or not their show what their
show's future is they don't know they
get it all like a couple months ahead of
time he just wants to keep playing back
in Japan he just wants to yeah and why
not he's great in it it's great a great
role for him yeah he doesn't know if
Netflix plans on doing that there's
there's a lot of stuff going on here
Disney has their own streaming service
who knows what plugs Marvel is actually
pulling but we'll see hopefully he'll
see him again in the role but let's move
on to our newest who's who's lightning
round
Ungh but here we go we get ready cuz
this is a five favorite segment from the
show now it's you guys know the drill
for the new rock stars news lightning
run you guys tweet us your questions I'm
gonna fire them at my co-host my coach
is gonna fire him right back at me Bing
bong and we've got to answer them as
quickly and without hesitation as
possible do you ready I'm ready
all right three two one we got one from
Morris Tina Terry what superhero other
than spider-man should get a turn at
being a musical mmm I would like to see
a white haze ago
good morning hook musical it's so sad
gotta have the music from the show Sam
at Josh stick 118 want to know what
video game do you think would work well
as a Netflix series in which Bioshock oh
yeah do the one in the air in the water
you got you call it Eric from Sunday
duck what is your favorite book to movie
adaptation book to movie had Oh Lord of
the Rings Lord of the Rings is three of
those amazing that's best done only good
one only good one true scorned wants to
know what do you think the Avengers
would dress up as for Halloween hmm
let's go to the classic ones Ironman
probably Robert Downey jr. you got Chris
set or you got Captain America you
probably go as a Statue of Liberty
Scarlett Ironman would dress up as a
junior which is a great joke from the
Ultimate Comics they like even cast
themselves and they cast Robert Downey
jr. as Iron Man anyway you could have
Hulk going as you could have him gone as
Clifford that'd be a good one the clip
of Big Red Dog
Hawkeye you could have him going as
Harvey Birdman sure from Birdman there
you go Scarlett Johansson Black Widow is
going to go as the windy slow go ah
there we go we got anybody else
no the authorities or Thor's gonna go as
a do any cast member from Point Break
yeah I love these multi-part questions
you easy to think of Eric from Joe
creamer 13 favorite moment on new rock
stars
favorite moment on new rock star yeah
yes oh um mm I knew that's a toughy like
like lightning lightning like um I like
to win what I did the New Year's baby
last year he's coming back this year
babies hold on dear diapers I'm a big
cat Rob Baker wants to know would you
prefer a buddy cop rom-com or straight
action vibe from the Winter Soldier
Falcon series buddy cop rom-com or
straight action straight action we don't
want any buddy cop but it got but I want
them I want them crime and we got to
stop it this is for both of us from woes
HP describe your morning routine start
with Eric cuz I got to think about it my
morning routine I brushed my teeth uh-oh
I make a list of everything I have to do
for the day and I look at a 538 Senate
projections and I feel really depressed
that's my morning routine in early
November 2018 oh boy well I wake up at a
balmy 6 a.m. go back to sleep till 9:30
so I basically blew the day and then I
wake up and I simultaneously floss with
a Waterpik brush my teeth wash my hair
wash my body all in the shower I get out
about two minutes
pretty good then I wear basically the
same clothes all week and then I well oh
I got a little no I and then I am coffee
coffee and coffee
they'll thanks everybody positions but
make sure your phone at new rock stars
on Twitter so you can says your question
that's the only way we can find when out
comes the time for a 15-second shout
outs each of us is 50 seconds to shout
out plug ramble but anything once Sam do
you got anything you want sure yes I on
Wednesdays and Thursdays if you go to
twitch.tv slash play noggin that's n o
GG i N
do a live show 4:00 p.m. PST Wednesday
you can get some news and some gaming
which is really fun it's mainly just
deep dives if like stuff I want talking
about like like in-depth movie reviews
where we get to like talk with the
audience which is really fun and also
like like bigger news stories and we're
playing the new jack box
we're making our way through it and it's
got some good games a new party pack oh
yeah and then Thursdays if you guys
watch the Super TV shows if we're
talking flash arrow Supergirl eight is a
shield Inhumans they're titans we're
watching Titans we actually do a live
review of all of those shows 4:00 p.m.
PST and also we do some on our patreon
as well to keep it going the flash this
season has been really good legends of
tomorrow is that hidden gem in the CW
world that actually barely is a
superhero show it's just delightful so
please join us there Eric what about you
I got man take two shoutouts I'm gonna
take mods and in Phillips my first
shoutout so as you know in addition to
hosting videos here for new rock stars
I'd like to do a lot of like live comedy
in the LA area and a month and a half
ago I did my Marvel parody show called
infinity fan and guys to show sold out
and I'm doing a new version of the show
in two weeks the two weeks from today
infinity fan show number two it's at the
same theater Acme theatre in North
Hollywood if you live in the LA area I
know some of you've reached at me
because I have that band nice shirt and
worried I'm a bad nice local like either
locally better my show it's it's super
funny and it's this show perfect for you
guys it's filled with like Marvel and DC
and Star Wars references and it's like
all the jokes that like I would love to
do here but some of them are just slip
it to dark to do here so I put them in a
live show it's like 45 minutes long
tickets will be available soon and you
could find info in the description below
follow me on Twitter Instagram because
I'll I'll go into all the details there
Tommy Beck told is a co-star and you've
seen him here on the show big fan it's
it's it's super funny and we we have
some new cast members and some new
sketches that we put in it that are I'm
very excited about for my second one
guys it's the final weekend if you live
in the United States you know if you if
you feel depressed about your life if
you're kind of mad and feel apathetic
that like you can't really change your
life and the system is rigged against
you you can vote if you're 18 years old
and if you haven't come
a serious crime you can vote and I know
it like you're tired of people telling
you that you that to vote and you feel
like it doesn't change anything but like
specifically you know you've probably
heard a lot of the top ballot things to
vote on like who's your senator is the
Senate gonna change is the house gonna
flip look at the propositions on your
ballot pay attention to who your
governor might be and who your state
senator and state representative because
on the local level those things affect
your life 10 times more and who's in the
White House or who's controlling senator
to the house and specifically on
California has got a butt ton of ballads
like measures they want to pass and they
are confusing so just sit around easing
give yourself 30 minutes you'll have
plenty of time to go over everything and
then just go vote you have two minutes
it takes two minutes you get to decide
whether we adhere to daylight savings
time in California that's one of the
things on the ballot and every state has
a different set of ballots that can
control how much you pay and rent how
much your gas is like these are things
that you deal with on a daily level how
much meat is and Barry that's gonna and
if you live in Florida my home state you
get to decide whether people who have
repaid their debt to society people have
committed crimes that were not seriously
violent or sex crimes ex-cons
get to have their natural right to vote
again because in Florida it's really
hard for people who have repaid their
debt to society and have been released
and are you know not bad people who were
very they do everything they can to
repay their debt to be taxpaying good
citizens and the current governor there
doesn't let them vote he just shuts it
down you're gonna change that you can
change the system 60% of Floridians who
vote decide to overturn that we're
talking like over a million people who
live in that state who now get to
participate in democracy you have the
chance to help these people out and if
no matter where you live look it I'm not
gonna tell you which way to vote just
like vote so you can like just nice if
ya participate right okay so those are
lightning round questions let's return
to our trivia question that we asked
earlier so as always loser will have to
join the gif and you'll see how that
works but let's see what the question
was once again it was in Game of Thrones
how stark was founded by bran the
Builder
who founded House Lannister Sam's answer
answer was my buddy Lance the spinster
mr. Allain spinster yeah that's a good
word Mary er sorry everybody Eric wrote
land the clever and that is the answer
land Oh famously tricked the former
owner of castle castle rock rock with
Casterly Rock
clean castle rock castle rock out of his
a land ownership and he liked stole it
from him and that's the Lannister way
sound like my Lance could do that my
buddy Lance is a pretty clever kid I was
able to pull that hold on we do have a
judge oh yeah judge you two split this
decision yes all right all right all
right so I'll do our good-byes Sam we'll
pull a task or gesture out of the gift
of shame box and we'll have to do it in
front of a green screen of which you
guys can take it and put anything behind
him when we have our animated gift that
we tweet out and he's gonna look like a
real dummy maybe you can make him do
whatever you want and I'll chant shame
at him while I say our goodbyes well
mine is just to make sure it makes sense
your hair keeps bursting into flames
even after you keep putting it out so
spontaneously whoo person who does the
social medias even put that on there so
you gonna make that work
or are you just gonna mime as if that's
happening yeah or maybe it will that's
on you guys go for it okay so when you
vote here we go is Sam shape Shay beard
that might be a good gift of just Sam
almost tripping falling to the monitor
all right Sam shame shame shame Oh Oh is
your hair on fire oh boy oh boy oh it's
jacket spread into his jacket hey
everyone thanks for watching this week's
episode of new rockstars news I would
like to thank my co-host Sam basher at
Sam bachelor on Twitter and I'm Eric vas
a da vas whoa way to commit comment down
below tweet us at new rock stars like
this video shape
and share this video around subscribe to
directs us to the deep times Wow into
all the stuff that you love outs oh boy
see you guys next week bye bye wash my
hair this morning so we're good I don't
you don't you're good